saves a lot of space in the floor pardon
I guess young Rises and scolding with
this small lineup out there now before
you got shooters all over the portaloo
cornet park back
[Music]
put it back on hardens hands against
Kobe white step-back jumper yes sir
not much you can do about that and
hardens on the move
harden fires over window boiling he won
the Rockets by seven
I agree with you Neal no effort but that
it looks it
the Bulls bench and Chris Dodd doesn't
say or to him where the Bulls are
struggle for the three-point line to 424
eight percent
here's heart for three that's good Jim
Boylan three for 45%
gobble that up the fella with 14
rebounds
outside part
[Music]
my goodness you have small target
it's marketed
just poke it in time out to boiling 21
times we hit 23 points by the bullets
that was a huge gap in the first half
here's heart
three and hardens over 40 what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content